MAN: Oh, my god.
WOMAN: It seems to
be like illuminating.
MAN: It's actually morphing
shape and rotating as well.
This is phenomenal.
Australia is certainly a
hotspot for UFO sightings.
We've had a phenomenal growth in
the reporting of UFO sightings
by the general public,
especially since the advent
of the internet.
But all evidence
shows that UFOs have
definitely been visiting
Australia for tens of thousands
of years.
We've had records
engraved on cave artwork
by the Australian
Aborigines, which
goes back thousands of years.
Australia is one of the
most mysterious continents.
And the Aboriginals have
all kinds of ancient stories
of sky gods coming down.
These are probably
some of the oldest
stories of extraterrestrial
intervention
that we have on planet Earth.
Australia was something
of a last frontier
long after America was settled.
Well, it was 1770 that the
British explorer Captain Cook
actually came across Australia.
And it wasn't until 1788
that it was really settled.
That was the east coast of
Australia settled by convicts.
That's what the British
brought from their prisons.
NARRATOR: Today, the area of
Sydney that the British first
settled is a bustling
metropolis and Australia
has become one of the most
popular tourist destinations
on Earth.
But hidden behind
this modern facade
is nearly 2.5
million square miles
of undeveloped and
sparsely populated
land, known as the Outback.
And while Australia is
a relatively new land
to the Western world, for the
nearly 700,000 people that
call the continent
their ancestral home,
it has a history that dates
back tens of thousands of years.
There's something very,
very special about Australia.
Here, we have a situation where
this huge landmass has been
pretty much cut
off from the rest
of the world for 40,000 years.
And we don't really find that in
many other places in the world.
NARRATOR: But what was happening
on this island continent
for the tens of
thousands of years
that it existed in isolation?
When the first
Europeans arrived here,
they didn't have much knowledge
in regards to the sky world,
where our people had
much ancient knowledge
of the star system and the
constellation of the stars.
Our knowledge and
wisdom is so old.
NARRATOR: Anthropologists
have dated the existence
of the Australian Aboriginal
people back 60,000 years,
making it the most
ancient continuous culture
in the world.
The Aboriginal
peoples of Australia
are one of the world's
very, very oldest cultures.
No other cultures in
the world can compare
with the Australian cultures.
They have knowledge that's
been around for a lot longer
than really any of our
knowledge has been around.
NARRATOR: The
aboriginal people have
no official written language.
Art, music, and
oral storytelling
are how they pass their
histories and sacred knowledge
to future generations.
Their past is encoded
on various rock walls
scattered across the continent.
Our oral traditions or
stories that are passed down
from generation to
generation, the wisdom
and knowledge that have been
given to us by our god--
they're 10,000 or more years
older than the Stonehenge
in England.
They're 20,000 or
30,000 years older
than the pyramids of Egypt.
NARRATOR: These ancient
traditions are all strongly
tied to Australia's
connection with the stars
and with the beings
that are said
to have come down from them.
As evidence, ancient
astronaut theorists
point to the caves of the
northwest Kimberley region
that contain depictions of
visitors called the Wandjina--
the sky heroes of one of
Australia's indigenous clans.